here tonight our two directors who are
still active and whose monumental
careers add up to one hundred and
eighteen years of moviemaking please
welcome the one man who gave us such
classics as the big parade the crowd
hallelujah street scene Stella Dallas
Northwest Passage war and peace duel in
the Sun and the other who directed
Camille bill of divorcement Little Women
born yesterday the Philadelphia Story
David Copperfield the women Gaslight my
fair lady and recently completed rich
and famous ladies and gentlemen mr. King
Vidor and mr. George Cukor
what a nice reception hi George
yes very nice indeed but you think it's
for our oh oh very great but you suppose
it's for our work or our age well we're
not getting any younger you know did you
remember the envelope certainly now
let's get almond okay action the
nominees for the best achievement in
directing our David Lynch for the
Elephant Man Robert Redford for ordinary
people
Martin Scorsese 4az going
Richard rush for the stuntman
roman polanski but test
may I have the envelope please no no
what do you mean no thanks thank you
and the winner is Robert Redford
I was thinking you know I wasn't
thinking I was just kind of blank but
you know how it is when somebody says to
you a few about a year before they say
you know if anybody told you a year ago
that you would have been dot dot dot
well I just didn't think I was going to
see this but I'm no less grateful and I
would like to express my debt for the
directors that I worked with in the past
for what I've learned from them
consciously or unconsciously
and I would also like to say that may
not be too fashionable but the fact is
that I really do appreciate the support
of Paramount Pictures Charlie blue darn
Barry Diller they let us make the film
the way we wanted to and I'm very
grateful for that there are a lot of
people that I can thank and I don't want
to go on too long but I couldn't go too
much further without expressing what for
me is the greatest gratitude and that
keys around the word trust I I really am
grateful for the trust that I received
from a terrific cast Mary
Donald Tim Judd Liz I love them and I
appreciate their love too so thank you
all
you